[Music]
Oh
[Music]
wrong with us - sure everything is wrong
with Zoey
[Music]
live enticing on campus by the fact she
had Galadriel hair which to be honest
this girl knows the way to my heart she
really happy monday welcome back to the
vlog so it's been a week since you've
lost in an extra the weather has turned
absolutely amazing and actually
surprisingly chill though to be fair the
entire unions in this weather so I mean
one little hidden alcoves on campus the
campus as I mentioned last time without
saying beautiful and this is a little
natural hidey hole we're bent just so I
can talk to you about what's going on
you might recall that last time I was
having problems and codes and I we
jigged it and I put in a different
language what's happened since then is I
have washed my hands of it and sent it
off because previously I had a consult
on the code at University of Reading he
was done this kind of problem the forks
nobody acts chair has done this
well what I'm what I'm doing cause it's
a very nice thing which has been part of
the problem I've had nobody to really
advise me on a specific application like
the technique I've had incredibly school
postdoc in the office but their
specifics nothing so very late on Friday
last week I sent off the codes who's
gone running saying look I've applied
everything exactly right this code works
it is fast it is almost correct but it's
just not right there's something missing
please Tom there must be some process
I've missed can you just have a look
through and if there's something obvious
which I trust it will be tell me and I
can fix it
they definitely showcases the advantage
of working in a team like we have a very
small research group of what we're
looking at here structural coupling and
in other places if girls working for
example actually Armenia or something
like that I would have more people to
ask about this kind
but I do have the benefit of having a
welcoming supervisor which means I can
email email this guy and hopefully he's
going to say oh you forgot to do this
step which nobody told me to do because
nobody here knows all so for those of
you who are questioning me doing redoing
things in Fortran
I wasn't redoing the whole script what I
did was basically use the Python script
I'd already written as a driver
so saying look this is where you're
getting your data from pull in the data
do a little bit manipulation on it and
then pass the process of the actual
inversion to a for transcript which is a
binary that you can import and then you
output it so basically what I'm doing is
using Python for this good app which is
like moving stuff around and I could
sort of quickly changing if I want to
say oh don't use of this data is this
data instead pythons great but then
using the really scientific language
using Fortran for the really specialized
work that needs to be done it's almost
like all the time I've been building a
really specialized tool and the Python
script says oh yeah this is where you
apply the tool and then it does its job
and then the Python script says right
you're done let's have a look at what
he's made so I'm using the both best of
both worlds basically so because the
scripts now at my hands I can return to
other things like looking through my
thesis but to be honest it does not like
a big weight and taking off my shoulder
like I'm not wholly responsible for the
outcome the code now nice to have some
help so I feel
a bit more relaxed don't you Ainsley
yeah boy it's terrifying
and so glad I bought this
[Music]
now that Sunday
nicely done in case I had to change by
the way because we're about to go
singing not much okay so I thought we
were saying it turns out we're not
actually singing oh that's one musical
director who realize this mistake well a
benefit are not singing if I can get a
longer running 10k gorgeous evening
Duchess I'm okay Hafiz I remember tired
last time running off today deadlifts
yesterday color hoes I thinking right
that's 6k in come on eventually apply to
I did it I say myself I wanted to do 10
gauge and that's 150 minutes I am so
pleased about that felt fast oh my god
yes I needed that so I mentioned
yesterday that I kept a carrying Hall of
Fame of all the things I've done wrong I
thought in order to make sure that I am
keeping it at the right level I would
take completely computer illiterate
person completely a completely coding a
literate person and yeah try explain why
I'm such an idiot
so one from when I was in Oxford was I
accidentally had burned entire planet
upside down which was an easy thing to
do in that I just said that instead of
counting from like the top nor port down
I thought it was can even self-taught up
rather it tells you things you know
maybe five of them I guess when you're
when you're quantifying the orientation
of the world through numbers that's
quite easy
yeah it's just good yeah it's just a
great one as mo you close those remarks
one identity too long ago I accidentally
put the earth had the earth radius
expand over time
basically I said that like the letter A
in the program equals the radius of the
earth house motor kilometers and that
because that's a relatively standard
thing to describe it in galaxy
nanocoatings be like a yeah but then
while also in relation the programs that
the each loop be like keep track of it
by saying that a equals one and then
behind gladly - yeah like this is making
no sense
I accidentally destroyed it but more
than a thousand lines of code by
pressing one button that alphabetize
them ah so it was like it was a thousand
lines of inversion and instead of you
know Bill is very important and how long
roughly will it take you to write out a
thousand lines of code and that was
several months of work it was like he
was building building building on blocks
and can you undo that yeah except there
wasn't immediate way to do it I tried to
control that and nothing happened and I
had like a cold sweat oh the worst one
was when I crashed the entire network of
the Oxford astrophysics department I
mean you think the worst I think that's
quite a feat if what happened what
amazing I was running this code for my
Master's project and it was quite
intensive it was because basically
logged into the server on the network so
you can do our local computer you said
it scientists over and you sent this
program off and they may have like
vomiting vitals and it kind of Hospital
they're like yeah the heart meter for
each of these servers been like for them
and I sent my neighbor and it kind of
trailed up to the top and then it went
in flatlined at the top hundred percent
load and then it just dropped off cliff
along with all the other ones so all the
load we had just went just to start and
then I was like anybody notice and I
step my head in the corridor and all
these other people's heads were out the
corridor could vary every computer
frozen at once now that's amazing I
didn't even know that was possible
were there any repercussions don't buy
this ability yeah that's my math talk
but what I think okay I think you know
if the tech guys have found out what
happened they would have just been
impressed
because I think computer people there
are far smarter people coding watching
this how did I do that because this
genuinely happened that still don't know
how I did it for a whole network - yeah
and local I don't even know how long it
took to reset reset because I left it
was working the next day so we have a
plan if you want to learn more about
space in dubious fashion then we just
started playing Kerbal space program on
Spungen electric oh my goodness it was
quite fun I enjoyed it quite a lot
yeah it's the thing is I don't quite a
bit about the game I know quite a bit
about space whereas you I know very
little about space and nothing okay it's
like the way I like think there is it's
like the first American missions we send
ships into space yeah in my defense they
managed to launch a satellite not a
conventional satellite it was a young
worker video and it was even a living
being you put into orbit you left him
that okay I did well I mean you did come
in he wasn't going to die so which is
odd compared for the rest of the crew of
that mission yeah what's that because it
was really fun and if you like it we'll
do more when we really lasting more
[Music]
well if I the gay pride week or its
international yank a day so I had a
slight problem this morning when my
phone overheated when my long will off
so I turned it off and then I woke up an
hour and a half later it's still in my
hand
yeah so I didn't really have a morning
with that I can't think why but for some
reason I'm really tired today I just had
lunch with Liv and I shot all those ton
lapses that you just saw and what I've
now got this afternoon is actually very
little planned apart from trying to
debug this previous okay which have been
working on and it was actually cool to
me whilst I was doing the time lapses
thinking right what hang on
it's like diagnose it don't don't
actually get stuck in straightaway think
about what you're doing which is
definitely something I don't do enough
so I'm kind of hopeful that this is
going to be productive so had a pretty
productive afternoon debugging the code
that's giving me JIT before and I
definitely like one chunk but I'm
rewriting now I am in one of eating
rooms in the building because I have a
super special google hangout but I can't
tell you about yeah I don't think I
didn't have a mission to talk about it
so yeah exciting announcement coming
sometime see
[Music]
okay
now that's done but it kind of looks
really nice outside so so three nice
evening and live wanted to go for a run
so what is the return of the greatest
superhero this geo inexperienced coding
boy and pixel girl it's absolutely
beautiful evening for a run better than
yesterday look at this pass on file
let's together come on look out alright
this so after that run I've had the
dullest evening I mean people have
commented on my video saying oh it's
just like KC or whatever those videos
but about really dull stuff this really
takes the biscuit because I've spent the
entire evening just emailing and moving
files around just really dull a pin it's
all admin that's dull now but it's
exciting stuff in the future like
sorting out details for Chapel Choir
tour this year event France behind the
scenes stuff on my YouTube to do with
making money from Amazon affiliate links
so like banking details I've also bought
a new 4 terabyte hard drive up here
because I generate so much stuff now I
mean every week I generate about 30
gigabytes of data and I don't delete
anything because you never know when it
will come in handy so yeah I'm now
moving about a terabyte over to that
like restructuring atom I thought this
is also so interesting and also
awkwardly now because I'm moving
everything over I can't actually do any
editing tonight I didn't really think
this through
so I'm losing an evening in terms
productivity burning it is half 10 and I
should probably go to sleep quite soon
because I shattered last night but might
just squeeze a little bit of level space
programming
and so Simon played Kerbal space program
for the next four hours learn from
Simon's lesson kids if you play lots of
the computer game you won't get much
sleep and they'll be a very grumpy boy
[Music]
jolly good
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]